[Musique]
il faut politiser le sujet de l'eau au
sens noble du terme il est pas encore
suffisamment inscrit dans les
différentes politiques publiques et donc
on a souhaité vraiment l'aborder pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une prise en
considération par l'ensemble des acteurs
bien sûr politique mais pas
exclusivement l'ensemble des parties
prenantes le Sénat c'est la chambre des
territoires et la politique de l'eau
c'est aussi la politique des territoires
et donc il est évident que le Sénat un
rôle majeur à jouer pour rassembler
toutes les idées tous les acteurs pour
voir comment on peut faire pour faire
des réserves de substitution récupérer
l'autre depuis faire de la réutilisation
des eaux usées mais aussi investir sur
les canalisations de potable on va
parler bien sûr de la quantité de la
qualité de l'eau et puis de la manière
dont on la gère avec des collectivités
locales la quantité il faut préserver
bien sûr les ressources et améliorer si
c'est possible les quantité des
composter donc aujourd'hui la qualité
des eaux nous sommes alertés déjà depuis
plusieurs mois et plusieurs années sur
une évolution de la qualité des eaux qui
parfois est bénéfique et parfois est
négatif parce que le spectre notamment
des polluants augmente de plus en plus
et puis en direction des collectivités
locales aujourd'hui il faut travailler
sur différents sujets notamment les
sujets aussi de la sobriété mais tout en
permettant aux collectivité locale
d'avoir les moyens disponibles pour
pouvoir faire face à ces enjeux donc
c'est aussi un sujet particulièrement
important